I'm Kim Goff Cruz and it is my privilege
to welcome all of you today to honor our
veterans
before we begin I would like to thank
our ROTC Cadets and midshipman for
presenting the colors
and to express our deep gratitude for
the to the Quinnipiac people for the
land on which we stand
I also want to acknowledge and recognize
our alumni leaders the Yale Alumni
Association is in the middle of a
meeting of the last couple of days they
have changed their schedule to join us
for the special event so welcome
but I also want to make a special
welcome and that's to the students The
Faculty staff and alumni who are with us
today who have served who are serving
and who are preparing to serve
we are so grateful all of us are so
grateful for the freedoms and privileges
that your sacrifices have made possible
now during our ceremony you will hear
from a veteran leader and a current
student
and we will also honor a staff person
who has supported and advocated for Yale
veterans
our speakers and honorees represent
commitment to honor and Country to our
veterans and to those who care for and
support them
before we begin it's my pleasure to
introduce president Peter salave who is
going to share his thoughts about rst
and Veterans president saliva
[Applause]
thank you Kim and good morning everyone
I'm really thrilled to see so many
students faculty members staff and
especially our alumni
with us today as we commemorate Veterans
Day and I wish to begin
by extending a special warm welcome to
the veterans and Yale ROTC students whom
we are honored to have here with us
you have our deepest gratitude and
respect for your contributions to our
country
for exemplifying a spirit of service
which dates to the founding of our of
our Institution
and of the Republic
indeed the call to serve Society was
inscribed
in this University's 1701 Charter
and this call has been answered
dutifully and with distinction
by generations of Yale students
faculty staff
and alumni for over three centuries
we think for instance of Nathan Hale
perhaps the most famous Yale alumnus to
serve in the American Revolution
who perished with the lone lament that
he had but one life to lose for his
country
we think two of the nearly thirty
thousand yelis who served in the first
and second world wars Korea and Vietnam
and service members up to the present
including those you see all around us
today who are carrying forward
a proud tradition
we also reflect with reverence on the
service of those veterans who are denied
Freedom even as they fought valiantly
for its cause
Patriots who as Dr Cortland van
rensselier Creed exclaimed still rallied
to the sound of Liberty and Union
Dr Creed the first African-American to
earn a medical degree at Yale served
honorably in the Union Army during the
Civil War
in spite of tremendous racism and
discrimination
closer to our time Patriots like
yelkalis alumnus and my friend retired
lieutenant colonel Enoch Woodhouse Woody
one of the last surviving Tuskegee
Airmen
endure endured segregated conditions in
defense of this country
I also think of Admiral Grace Hopper who
earned her PhD at Yale and is the
namesake of one of our residential
colleges she led in fields that were at
the time unwelcome to women
and now in our era
we were resolved to build as best we can
on their enduring Legacies
yells Reserve Officers Training Corps
program for instance was recently lauded
by U.S Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin
for increasing diversity through the
officers it produces including
in areas of the active duty force that
are underrepresented by women
Yale law school meanwhile is at the fore
of the effort to rid the veterans
benefit system
of racial disparities
and earlier this semester
U.S news and World Report recognized
yell
as the best college in the nation for
veterans
in part due to our commitment
to ensuring that a Yale education is
Affordable
to everyone
I don't love those rankings but I do
love it when we're number one
of course
our tradition of service continues
through the students who will one day
join the eminent ranks
of the Yale veterans community
the ROTC program on campus recently
marked the 10th anniversary
of its return
and the spirit of sacrifice that links
these and future military members is a
Hallmark of the spirit
of Yale itself
it is the desire to ensure the security
and Welfare of this and future
Generations
it is the desire to serve to look Beyond
self-interest
it is in short
the desire to contribute
to the common good
deeply grateful for the veterans here
with us today who have given of
themselves to a better world
and for the cadets and midshipmen of our
ROTC program
who have similarly felt and answered the
call to duty
your decision to serve in the armed
forces is especially critical during
this period of global turbulence
conflicts are escalating
democracies are backsliding
and right now the spirit of division
around the world
seems stronger than ever
yet today
we look around this room
and this community
and what we see is the spirit of service
it's a spirit forged over centuries
indeed the fabric of our nation is woven
by the individuals who have defended it
for nearly 250 years
the resilience and wisdom of our
veterans helped to build a nation
and their strength help to bind it
together during difficult times
their courage helped save a world torn
apart by War
twice
their determination has protected
Millions from a life of Oppression
and hardship
and as recent years have underscored
their compassion and commitment to
humanity
have brought food
clothing and shelter medication
to those in need of it most
the exigent crisis we face as a country
and Global Community remind us anew
of the fragility of peace
that they also redouble our gratitude
for those who have answered the call
to protect it
in both peacetime and wartime elas have
answered this call to duty
and many have made the ultimate
sacrifice
for their country
carved into the hallowed walls of
Memorial Hall right outside those doors
you can find the names of 1020 Yale
alumni killed in battle
since the American Revolution
out on Hewitt quadrangle the memorial
cenotaph honors 225 Yale students and
alumni who died in the Great War
and the Ledyard Flagstaff is dedicated
to the memory
of a young Yale alumnus
who died during the Philippine American
War
today we assemble in the shadow of these
campus landmarks and in awe
of Valor to which they pay tribute
and of the veterans who gave their
loyalty
to this nation
I join a grateful university community
and saluting those
who have so nobly served this country
and advanced the cause of peace
around the world
thank you all very much
thank you
foreign
right
[Music]
now
[Music]
perfect
first
Grand architects of the universe
called by many names
in many languages by many voices
today we ask that your guiding hands
hold us
and all sisters and brothers in military
service near
we are grateful to all who now serve all
who have served and for those who in the
words of President Abraham Lincoln gave
the last full measure of devotion in
service of their country
we are joined in humility gratitude and
our own measure of devotion knowing that
as we seek to understand an increasingly
complex world
we are sheltered by the vigilance
service of citizens to our Republic
we ask special regards for those who
have served but who have not yet been
found and returned home
and for those who have returned but who
have yet to find themselves at home
we honor our military and ask that
whatever is required of them
be informed by your Infinite Wisdom
the light and Truth as they honorably
and loyally seek to create a peaceful
and secure future for us all
amen
good afternoon president solve a
secretary Goff Cruz Provo Strobel
director bajwa Rod Lowe Dean sodi the
Veterans Day committee distinguished
guest family and friends members of our
community and of course our veterans
to everyone here today thank you for
coming together to celebrate those who
during times of peace and War swore to
defend our nation and its most sacred
principles
it's a privilege to be with you all
today at an event hosted by a university
with such a long-standing and storied
tradition of service
only a few moments walk away stands a
statue of one of this nation's earliest
and finest Patriots placed adjacent to
the building he called home while a
student here at Yale
Nathan Hale's famous last words that his
only regret is he had but one life to
lose for his country embodies the same
principle that is held by every person
who has worn our military's clot
if you speak to a hundred different
veterans you'll hear a hundred different
stories but one principle is universally
true
each and every one of them pledged to
serve a cause far greater than self at
Great personal expense and without any
Assurance of what the future may hold
I'm continually humbled and inspired by
those with whom I served and by the
veterans I've met since hanging up my
uniform and I want to thank everyone
here today who has warned currently
wears or one day will wear our nation's
uniform
my story with the military like many
others does not begin with a family
tradition of Marshall service I never
really thought about joining the
military until my senior year of high
school
at the time all I knew was that I had to
get away from home and the military
seemed like a good opportunity to do so
the determining factor of why I chose to
enlist in the Marines was in all honesty
that I like their uniforms the best
which I suppose is somewhat ironic since
I didn't know the Marines had flight
suits and that's the uniform I ended up
wearing the most
and so I shipped off to boot camp
shortly after my high school graduation
not sure of what would become of me
I'll never forget that first night in
boot camp I remember thinking repeatedly
that I had made the worst decision of my
life
but as you quickly learn in the military
you must adapt to new situations and
challenges and Excel in stressful
environments whether it's making your
bed with a perfect 45 degree fold in the
corner while a drill instructor screams
in your face or calling an osprey to the
deck at night in heavy dust while the
enemy lurks in the Darkness
and so my initial apprehension gave way
and as the Marine Corps became my new
home I realized that I had made the
greatest possible decision by enlisting
well I look back fondly on many moments
with some of the greatest people I'll
ever know my time in the military also
created some of my greatest struggles
and leaving those in the past at one
point seemed insurmountable
returning home from deployment was one
of the hardest things I've ever had to
do
deployment itself was challenging enough
it was hard to start each day with a
brief on the number of enemy killed in
action over the previous 24 hours and
the weapon systems we are expected to
encounter throughout our flight
to navigate through airbursts and wonder
if the next one would be the one that
took us down to see cities destroyed by
airstrikes and the ravages of War
to point a machine gun at another human
being and have to decide if he was the
enemy hiding within a civilian
population or an innocent bystander
caught in the middle of a war he didn't
ask for
but it was also hard to return from that
to a place that no longer felt like home
to go about each day feeling like a part
of me was lost in the desert
it was hard to leave behind a place
where I felt that everything I did
mattered not knowing if I'd ever have
that purpose in my life again
it was harder still to leave behind the
military along with the people who were
there with me throughout it all
for several years after leaving the
Marines I didn't want anything to do
with the military
I avoided reaching out to those I served
with and I did everything I could to
reclaim who I was and leave the military
forever in the past
but that's easier said than done
my non-commissioned officer blood Strife
were beaten in my legs and my sergeant
Chevrons were pounded into my chest I
fought for my wings in the Skies over
Iraq and I earned the right to wear the
eagle globe and anchor
these things are not given lightly and
once given nothing can take them away
I'm grateful that they'll always be with
me and I no longer lament a part of me
that never returned from the desert or
avoid the memories of my time in uniform
because those things made me who I am
today
I'm forever grateful for those who help
me along this journey Professor Jeannie
Johnson for helping me find a path when
I was left the Marines and for being a
friend and Mentor for nearly half a
decade Rose mcard for helping me
navigate service after the military and
for growing my love of foreign policy
and international relations
Genie was my professor during my first
semester of college well I certainly
felt out of place
in our freshman introductory
international relations course as a
former Marine Sergeant with a disheveled
beard who had barely graduated high
school
Jeannie recognized that I understood the
importance of the material we were
learning because I had lived through
international relations at its most
visceral level in Iraq
she immediately took me under her wing
and supported me constantly ever since
Rose was my supervisor at the state
department as an army officer who joined
the state department after transitioning
from active duty Rose quickly became an
inspiration to me as I sought to regain
a sense of purpose in life
because of my experience in the Marines
and Rose's belief in me I was able to
work on Project whose effects are right
now being used by Ukraine to defend its
independence to represent State
Department equities to the National
Security Council and to help formulate
policy as crises develop throughout the
world because of Genie and Rose I found
my post-military purpose in life in
foreign relations
but Genie and Rose's support for me
highlights something far more profound
veterans bring something to the table
that is impossible to find anywhere else
veterans have real world experience that
has gained in the most trying of
circumstances skill sets that are
developed in furtherance of the most
serious tasks and an ability to succeed
in the most challenging environments
I'm grateful for the incredible faculty
at Yale law school for recognizing this
at the start of Fort Durham Dean Gerkin
immediately set to work supporting
veterans and thanks to her efforts Yale
law school isn't just the best place to
study law but is a place that veterans
can truly call home
one of the greatest Testaments to Yale
Law's commitment to Veterans is the
Veterans Legal Services Clinic which
under the leadership of Mike wishney
Megan Brooks and Jason Parkins is a
significant engine of improvement to
veterans benefits and has changed the
lives of countless Veterans for the
better it's telling that every semester
there's overwhelming student interest to
work in the clinic
I also wouldn't be here today without my
family support it can't be easy for any
parent to watch their child ship off to
war and I can't imagine the burdens my
parents felt knowing they signed my
contract for me when I was too young to
enlist on my own
our military families deserve nothing
but the highest our nation's highest
respect and gratitude they hold together
families on their own for months and
years they say goodbye to parents
siblings children and significant others
and live through periods of incredible
stress limited communication and immense
worry
they often put their lives on hold and
move to places far from familiar faces
nothing we could do could ever repay the
sacrifices you all have made
and of course I'm grateful for those who
are no longer with us whose sacrifices
are the reason we can be together today
and many Marine Corps ceremonies there's
an empty Place set at a table for a
fallen well at first this table to me
was just a solemn reminder of the nature
of military service as the years have
passed more and more friends have come
to occupy that empty seat you live with
me every day and I'm forever thankful
for our memories together
while I once ignored this day Veterans
Day is now a day that I take pride in
the best parts of my service and try and
heal from the difficult ones smile back
on fond memories and Express gratitude
for the challenges that the military
imposed cherish those who are still with
us and honor those who are gone knowing
that my time in the military has given
me the tools to overcome the
insurmountable and I'll always find
inspiration and my brothers and sisters
as they navigate their own paths
to my fellow members of the Armed Forces
however you choose to spend Veterans Day
I'm grateful to be here with you all
today thank you for answering the call
wherever you may be in your journey
whether you're a member of our ROTC who
is training to take charge of your first
command you left the military decades
ago or you fall somewhere in between
I hope the future brings you nothing but
joy and know that your brothers and
sisters are rooting for your success
thank you for taking the time today to
honor our veterans may we honor them
every day by enjoying the blessings of
this nation that they served thank you
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
rest
of it
okay all right so we just so you know
that our our student is okay she's
talking she just fainted it is a little
bit hot in here I have to say
I mean I don't think they were expecting
to be here for that long but but she's
fine and we will continue with our
program okay
um and actually why don't we give a
round of applause to our students by the
way
and Michael I want to tell you are your
comments were really quite wonderful so
we're really grateful that you shared
your story with us and that you chose to
come to Yale so welcome and thank you
now one of the things that was really
poignant about what Michael was talking
about was the the need to have people in
your sphere who support you as a veteran
wherever you may be including at Yale
and right now we want to as a university
recognize someone who has made
outstanding contributions to Veterans
with the Veterans Day tribute award
this year it is my great honor to
present the award to Risa sodi the
assistant Dean and director of academic
advising and special programs in Yale
College
Risa
now many of us may know recent because
she has been at the University for 25
years
but for the last nine years she has been
the director of the Eli Whitney program
the Eli Whitney student program and the
transfer student programs and most of
our Yale College student veterans find
their way to Yale and to New Haven
through those two programs
in 2013 there were six student veterans
in the Eli Whitney program but today
there are 36. and Dean sodi continues to
provide the same individualized and
loving attention and support to each Eli
Whitney student with Grace and
generosity
her support has made countless students
feel as if they belong at Yale
for example
former Eli Whitney student Yale college
graduate and current Yale law school
student Hillary Browning recalls feeling
really cared for the moment she met Dean
sodi
in Hillary's time at Yale College dean
Saudi provided not only academic support
but also personal guidance which she
said really helps us to succeed
but in addition to a supports of
students student veterans and the like
she has also served on the Veterans Day
ceremony committee for many many years
and so her dedication and support to
Veterans to Yale's veterans in
particular are recognized
today for the service that goes beyond
the student Community to the entire
veterans community
so Risa I am really pleased to present
with you to you today this award if you
come and join me
on behalf of the Veterans Day committee
in recognition of your support for all
of our veterans at Yale please join me
in welcoming her and also sharing our
admiration and respect for her service
thank you
now I just saw that Senator Blumenthal
has joined us and I want to make sure
that if you have time to make some
comments that would be wonderful for us
welcome another Alum as well so thank
you
thank you
thank you congratulations Dean Scotty
and uh congratulations to
Yale very proud to be a graduate of the
law school here as our two of my
children and another of my children a
graduate of the college
and over the years I
have
seen Yale
become more and more
respectful
I think is the right word of our
veterans since the days when I came here
as a law student shortly after
the Vietnam War
and Yale has been at the Forefront of
recognizing the immense contributions
made by our veterans
in a way that I think has provided a
model for other
educational institutions as I've seen
them around the country
I serve on the Veterans Affairs
committee as well as on the armed
services committee
and I think the pattern in our great
nation the greatest in the history of
the world is that all too often
we fail
we utterly fail
to address the needs
of our veterans give them what they
deserve when they most need it
in the aftermath of their service
and that is true of the post-911
generation of Veterans as well only
literally this Congress
did we succeed in passing a measure
it's called the pack act that will
provide care and benefits for veterans
exposed to toxic chemicals poisons burn
pits on the battlefield
3.5 million veterans
but it took years to do it I started
working on it a number of years ago it
was bipartisan
but the VA actually opposed us
in this effort just as it opposed us
when we sought to get
care and benefits for
veterans who suffered as a result of
Agent Orange exposure
a generation before and it took
literally a generation to get that
coverage
and now the pack act will provide
the presumption of service connection
when people develop
23 different kinds of cancers or
liver disease emphysema all of the
Hideous diseases that result from
being in the way of
these toxic chemicals
if burn pits were located
anywhere around
Yale or around New Haven or anywhere in
Connecticut anywhere in the United
States they would be a scandal there
would be Mass protests but our military
men and women were exposed to these
toxic chemicals day after day
and I am sure some of the veterans here
today
know people who have
suffered from those diseases
so
I think one of the lessons is that
honoring our veterans this day
fine to do
I'm proud of our state
for having numerous ceremonies and I've
been to several of them already
rhetoric words
are good
but even better and even more important
and Our obligation is to honor veterans
indeed an action not just in Word
if you know a veteran who has
been in the military and deployed
as two of my sons have during these 20
years of war make sure they get screened
on just this last Tuesday every one of
them is eligible for screening
make sure they get screened because
cancers like glioblastoma
or
more to the point kidney liver diseases
can be caught early
and we need to invest in education skill
training health care for our veterans
not only the physical wounds of War
that are apparent when people leave but
also the invisible wounds of War like
these cancers that don't manifest until
years after or
PTS
and other
mental health issues
thank you for
what you'll do
to make sure that our veterans are taken
care of
we're very fortunate to have here in
West Haven one of the best VA hospitals
in the whole country
it needs more investment as well again
action not just work
and thank you to Yale thank you to
everyone who is here today for keeping
faith with our veterans and honoring
them as you're doing today thank you
very very much
all right are you ready for a military
salute
all right
let's get going this is almost like the
Harvard Yale game but this is like so
we're going to really hear it now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one two three
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
let us go forth from this place of
profound memory and deep meaning with
grateful hearts grateful for the service
and sacrifice of our veterans and their
families
let us never forget all that they have
done to bravely protect freedom and
human rights
from the moment our veterans made the
commitment to serve
they were committing to a life that
would be forever changed
may we be ever mindful that the life of
a veteran is always multi-dimensional
and is rooted in the pride and promise
of Liberation coupled with the
ever-present possibility of peril for
alienation
all of these things are held in tension
and contain the longing for a certain
kind of peace
to revive our weary world
as we honor our veterans and we seek to
grow closer to this abiding peace may we
come to know a peace born from wisdom
and understanding a peace nurtured with
compassion and mercy a piece
strengthened by courage and commitment
and may may we all be blessed this day
and every day by the shimmering light of
our god of many names Our God who
creates sustains and Embraces all life
amen
so that is our ceremony and I want to
thank you all for coming
um many thanks to the planning committee
and the particularly our team in of
student life office the secretary's
office who I know the military is
prepared to make changes in a dime but
they have done pretty well so I want to
thank you very much for changing
everything quickly
um
to our participants in our program thank
all of you for being on the stage with
us and I also want to give a special
shout out to the Yale College of the
Yale School of Music brass Ensemble
really
so as we as we close I want us to
remember that when today has passed
and when we return to our busy lives and
they are busy nowadays
I want us to remember to continue to
remember the men and women of Yale who
have Faithfully
and honestly served all of us to they
protected us they've served us we are a
stronger and more diverse Community
because of them
so thank you all for your service and
have a really really good day
[Applause]
foreign